[Music]
told your mother i could take good care
of you
[Music]
i love you more than anyone in this
whole wide world
[Music]
her mom is dead
she'll be better off here no she won't
what's her name
you can call her whatever you want
you'll be my little angel from now on
[Music]
angel
how did you end up with these plates
she doesn't talk about her past
you got any plans
plans
[Music]
she can't keep me here
you forgot where i found you missy
i made you a princess
feel the power ranger
the only girls who leave here are too
old too sick to work
they're dead
i'm gonna kill you
[Music]
[Music]
no one gets within a foot of hurt for
free
i have to meet her
what's your pleasure mister i didn't
come here for that i
[Music]
heard you're gonna marry me
take me away from here
give me the life i deserve
i've got too many demons i don't know
how to love
you did not she lose the life you had
but you can't choose life you won't
[Music]
he deserves a decent girl not you
did you think i couldn't find you
you have to stop thinking that i'm going
to be something that i'm not
that way is home
a choice
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you